well in terms of applications that very
simple and it applies to everything that
we have in this world wouldn't go to
mission first of all the ethical has
issued by study I'm sure the force that
exists around which is a bit kind of
conclusive you or inclusive okay force
of nature which is what we call God but
it's actually it's a physical nature of
force okay but one that is higher than
our own nature because it is all about
love and giving with you and that's why
we don't feel it because we're opposite
from it hydrogen and helium but when we
begin it got it David to come closer
will eliminate the devil in our nature
to that and that's what couple are
teaches us Leah favorite igual then we
begin to employ that power on ourselves
it gives us a chance to permeate to
permeate it and then it's expressed in
all of our actions in your family and
education of children in the way we
manage perform our jobs we walk there
and in the professions that we study too
because and I learned a lot of things
through it because we learn how this
force kind of dresses in matter how it
acts in inanimate in the plants and
animals and people very loving it helps
us understand all of life's systems we
might have not a clue that will lead you
Oh political systems economical system
is because of psychological ones human
relations family relations how to have a
better education that work culture comes
from be with you say now for example
vision eww okay now in my current
Rizzuto New York I met with
psychologists musicians just today we
met mobi politicians of a ship she will
just keep it and people who really
engage in every area of human engagement
and I I find that I have a lot to talk
to them about and I see
that we met yesterday milegi David I've
got something to say to them they have
something to add to me and with my
experience in all the places in the
world that I've come to and engage with
people Keysha revered later on have a
lot of work we filled with all with
people from all walks of life and any
fields of expertise this comprehensive
knowledge about the force of nature
Antebellum with you which couple of ads
to us we can add it it's like a spice
that you add to every way of life than
you had a hero and especially to
education by echelon yeah because our
problem is that if we could educate just
a single generation before anahola in
the right way they would educate their
own kids correctly in the right in the
right way the home of the Kabbalah must
be Elena and Caroline explain how we can
approach with education she remained in
a way that brings him up as good people
the shelf needs a memo and I'm very
happy that much better there that
actually precisely because of the
current crisis in you might be going
because that is affecting the whole
world as usual so people are finding the
key to the Levine share to be a more
attentive and to understand that the
main problem is human education a Louis
that may be able to stop using before
our egos so wildly but Caillou like for
example the financiers and all those who
are very euro issue and I can see that
it produces good results actually
commissioned that's how is it that me
write a lady with it we will see our
children grandchildren having a better
life as a result
well of course it will tell it like our
whole world should behave basically as
it does you just have to add a few
corrections to America below marriage
kabbalah centre of before we have now
big but who died come into the state
measure kuduro in the evolution of our
egos over the generations these guys now
that we we've evolved to a state where
all kind of closed in together come on
regulation IM shimizu it's like
cogwheels all tied together working
together valve conduction cool i would
love and that's the state of the whole
world right now and it'll even it will
be even more so with the so as we need
to learn what is keep your magic as grow
a cybernetic a closed system it's a
hokey really what kind of laws are
applied in it by which formula we have
to manage our lives right now the result
is and that was my first profession bio
cybernetics shape America's old in such
a system at the royal court Leslie you
cannot succeed in my gosh if you have no
consideration of the entire system of
illéa honey holy cliche but how can I be
considerate of 7 billion people as push
it more it's very simple gonna be mad at
me mother holt we me that matter
honolulu medium what we learned from the
science of systems 57 ethics and from
the ways of kabbalah you have a very
simple formula hole at them every person
the cold asic should be every business
in the world may I over from this day
onwards can succeed it only on condition
of it that it works without any surplus
profit Haley Kenosha Terry McKay even or
mine only what it needs to sustain
itself in a kind of normal way where I
be directed only nice way can we move
forward anamika bishop I'm hopeful that
today at one time economists will
understand it baby Clara energy machine
entails especially those who are in
business Sabrina just because they won't
have a choice area because either we
learn it
out of troubles and she crises or you
can see Monica by using science and
Kabbalah both of which speak of the same
thing that you died yesterday it is a
very basic simple formula if business
got a pig your employees you gotta pay
insurance you gotta pay your own salary
you could pay for pension and field or
mining holiday for what not and for a
vacation is what you do but that's it
unless you're not more than that leaving
nothing that is surplus profits the rest
but so is it will come back to you in a
negative way there hopefully that's the
law of closed systems which humanity
later today is kind of emerging into
historically mode we're going to have to
learn it work and then when you coming
years you might as well let's hope we
learn it not really do a lot of trouble
spot just by attaining it see